merci mamie frérot nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu de Paris monte du groupe
socialiste et vous êtes également
conseillé de Paris et on va revenir sur
ce qui s'est passé cette explosion dans
le 5e arrondissement de la capitale les
recherches qui se poursuivent pour
retrouver une personne toujours portée
disparue dans les déco parce que vous
avez plus d'informations non je n'ai pas
personnellement plus d'informations mais
je sais que une personne disparue est
toujours recherchée et puis
s'est mis en place
une véritable
organisation de prise en charge des
victimes des familles qui doivent être
logées d'un quartier aussi qui a besoin
d'être soutenu d'être conforté moi je
veux évidemment avoir une pensée pour
les victimes pour leur famille pour
leurs proches saluer les secours et
l'ensemble des services publics qui se
sont mis au travail pour justement venir
en aide aux victimes et aux habitants
et les habitants sont relogés par la
mairie il y a encore des habitants des
habitants qui en avait besoin qui en ont
besoin ont été relogées par la mairie
par les bailleurs sociaux leur nombre
n'est pas très important de ce que j'ai
vu dans dans les chiffres mais bien sûr
la tension qui leur est portée est très
forte et c'est à la mairie du 5e
arrondissement qui est organisé
l'accueil la prise en charge je pense
aussi à la prise en charge psychologique
qui est un élément extrêmement important
y compris pour tous les habitants du
quartier qui sont en état de stress en
état de choc et qui ont besoin
d'accompagnement est-ce que vous avez
plus de précisions sur l'origine de
l'explosion non je n'ai pas plus de
précision j'ai
ce sont les enquêteurs c'est la justice
qui doit trouver les causes précises de
cette explosion il semblerait que ce
soit dû à une fuite de gaz à quel
endroit de quelle origine je ne n'en
sais pas plus et par ailleurs il n'y a
pas non plus de certitude encore à ce
stage je pense qu'il faut faire vraiment
confiance aux enquêteurs et leur laisser
le temps de faire leur travail
sereinement on va parler d'un autre
sujet d'actualité on l'a vu dans le
journal hier et aujourd'hui sont réunis
à Paris à l'initiative d'Emmanuel Macron
plusieurs dirigeants mondiaux un sommet
pour un nouveau patte financier mondial
l'objectif c'est d'aider les pays en
finance en développement pardon à lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique à
faire face à la pauvreté c'est une bonne
initiative d'Emmanuel Macron c'est une
bonne initiative oui ensuite il y a
beaucoup de communication dans
l'initiative parce qu'il n'y a pas de
résultats concret à ce sommet mais le
fait qu'il y ait une mobilisation à la
fois pour financer la transition
écologique dans le monde entier pour
soutenir les pays du Sud dans cette voie
et pour essayer d'éviter l'augmentation
de cette fracture nord-sud qui est un
des éléments les plus inquiétants du
monde d'aujourd'hui pour aider les pays
du Sud à investir tout cela est
évidemment
va dans le bon sens ensuite ça restera
de belles paroles mais que ça n'aboutira
pas sur des actes on a vu déjà qu'il y a
des aides du FMI qui vont être fléchés
vers ces pays alors du FMI de la Banque
mondiale mais on voit à la fois le
retard pris ces dernières années pour
financer la transition énergétique il y
a besoin de centaines de milliards
d'euros d'investissement chaque année et
puis on voit
l'insuffisance des efforts encore là il
n'y a pas de mesures à ce sommet il y a
une mesure qui est envisagée qui est de
taxation des émissions carbone du
transport maritime c'est bien mais tout
cela est très insuffisant et quid des
d'une taxe sur les transactions
financières sur le transport aérien et
d'une taxation des grandes fortunes dans
le monde entier pour justement financer
cette solidarité la lutte contre la
pauvreté et la transition écologique de
la planète
Macron il a dit nous avons une taxe sur
les transactions financières nous avons
une taxe sur les compagnies aériennes
nous avons mis en place les deux mais il
déplore que le reste du monde ne suivent
pas vous le suivi vous le suivez vous là
dessus bien sûr mais
n'exagérons pas ce que la France a fait
il a l'embellie beaucoup la réalité et
tout ne repose pas en effet sur Emmanuel
Macron et que fait la France aussi pour
engager un mouvement qui soit beaucoup
plus fort il y a sous comme souvent chez
Manuel Macron plus de mots que d'actes
mais là en l'occurrence la réunion de ce
sommet était une bonne initiative et il
faut qu'on se mobilise les politiques la
société civile les ONG l'ensemble des
gouvernements qui veulent avancer pour
aller plus vite aller plus loin voilà on
a déjà beaucoup de retard le temps
presse on va continuer à parler finances
vous êtes à la commission des finances
unifero le gouvernement qui a annoncé
cette semaine vouloir faire 10 milliards
d'économies on va voir tout ça dans le
détail avec Quentin calmé
[Musique]
bonjour Quentin bonjour Oriane bonjour
Rémy frérot et Quentin le gouvernement a
fait de premières annonces sur ses choix
budgétaires des prochaines années en
tout cas d'ici à la fin du quinquennat
même dans les prochains modèles
l'après-midi c'est venu clore ces
assises sur la fiscalité c'était lundi
le gouvernement qui dit avoir identifier
déjà 10 milliards d'économies ils visent
un total de 12 milliards au total pour
le budget 2024 notre devoir collectif et
désormais de protéger notre nation
contre la dette a dit le ministre de
l'Économie on comprend qu'il s'agit de
tourner la page du quoi qu'il en coûte
fin la tournée encore une fois puisque
ça fait plusieurs fois qu'ils disent
qu'il faut tourner cette page mais
plusieurs pistes cette fois-ci ont été
avancées Oriane par l'exécutif pour ce
budget regardez on les a résumés déjà il
y a la lutte contre la forte
augmentation des arrêts maladie le
contrôle des dérives je cite la Bruno Le
Maire des dépenses en médicaments la fin
des aides au logement avec la saint du
dispositif Pinel et la refonte du prêt à
taux zéro la fin aussi des avantages
fiscaux sur certains carburant et pour
certaines professions comme les
transporteurs routiers ou les
agriculteurs Ariane et quels sont les
réactions Sénat sur ces premiers fils
Quentin par exemple sur ce plateau
Philippe vous voyez qui était à votre
même place hier notamment sur la
question des médicaments de la santé
écoutez
explosion des arrêts maladie dérivent
des dépenses en médicament ils peuvent
faire des économies là-dessus vous le
suivez alors sur le sur les maladies la
réponse est oui seul médicament je suis
beaucoup plus prudent parce que à la
fois le niveau de prescription des
médicaments mais à travers le
financement médicament il y a aussi tout
le financement de la recherche donc
voilà donc on peut pas faire un résumé
aussi rapide on connaît aujourd'hui on
n'a pas tenu le maire on connaît les
aujourd'hui les Suisses sur lesquels
nous devons regarder très près mais le
sud de la santé doit être pris avec
parcimonie parce qu'on voit bien
aujourd'hui que la santé va mal en
France
et autres préoccupation font les
sénateurs Quantin le sang des
collectivités locales bien sûr
collectivité locale ont toujours les
sénateurs il y a beaucoup d'inquiétudes
autour de ce sujet mais effectivement en
plus dans le contexte d'un boycott de
ses assises de la fiscalité par les
trois principales associations d'élus
les maires de France les départements et
les régions ça a fait l'objet de quatre
questions au Gouvernement mercredi lors
de la séance des questions d'actualité
au Gouvernement écoutez un extrait d'une
de ces questions des sénateurs avec la
communiste Cathy a poursu poli vous êtes
avec les collectivités
il y a
y a que leur quotidien y compris de
dialoguer avec celle et ceux qui chaque
jour sont sur le terrain je parle des
élus locaux voilà Katia pour ce
politique d'ailleurs que les
collectivités locales ont de plus en
plus de mal à boucler leur budget en
cause la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation il y a plusieurs années et
puis celle plus récente de la CVAE cette
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises on en avait beaucoup parlé
lors et bien des grandes réunions de ces
élus locaux à l'automne dernier Oriane
vous vous en rappelez les collectivités
de territoriales on le sentiment de
perdre tous leurs levier budgétaire le
gouvernement de son côté se défend en
disant que la prochaine loi de
programmation va entériner en septembre
un nouvel effort de l'État plus
important que celui demandait aux
collectivités locales Rémy ferrot tout
d'abord sur les premières annonces sur
ces 10 milliards de réduction de la
dépense qu'est-ce que ça vous est ce que
cela vous évoque c'est une bonne
décision politique elle est responsable
selon vous vous voyez la contradiction
il y a Emmanuel Macron qui dit hier il
faut un choc de financement public pour
financer la transition écologique dans
le monde la lutte contre la pauvreté et
deux jours avant 10 milliards de rabots
sur les dépenses sur la santé sur le
logement j'ai trouvé ça ahurissant même
sidérant et sur les collectivités
locales qui sont déjà impuissantes
aujourd'hui par l'impossibilité d'avoir
des ressources nouvelles le gouvernement
qui veut leur faire faire des économies
alors qu'on sait que partout dans le
monde et c'est vrai en France aussi ce
sont les investissements des
collectivités territoriales qui
permettent de lutter contre le
changement climatique et de d'organiser
cette transition sur les territoires
donc il y a une profonde incohérence
dans la politique du gouvernement et là
en l'occurrence l'annonce de ces 10
milliards d'économies souvent de bouts
de chandelles etc j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment c'est pas du tout ce dont notre
pays a besoin on va revoir les pistes
évoquées par l'exécutif si vous le
voulez bien puisque vous avez déjà
évoqué le logement et les médicaments
est-ce que dans ces quatre pistes qui
sont déjà annoncées il y en a que vous
pourriez soutenir ou est-ce qu'elles
sont toutes ou transferts selon vous il
y en a une qui va dans le bon sens et
ensuite il faut l'organiser c'est de
mettre fin progressivement à ce qu'on
appelle les niches fiscales brunes et
vous montrer vous-même la dernière ce
qu'il faut sortir justement de cette
dépendance fossile oui donc c'est celle
qu'il faut organiser mais pour
l'organiser il faut aussi des ressources
nouvelles le refus absolu du
gouvernement de mettre en place taxation
sur les hauts patrimoine ou sur les
hauts revenus de remonter la fiscalité
du capital et bien il se prive des
ressources dont on a besoin pour
organiser cette transition
on en revient toujours à ces questions
du ruissellement l'exécutif qui voilà
veut réduire le taux position parce que
il est parmi les plus hauts dans la zone
euro en France
quand vous additionnez l'ensemble des
niches fiscales ça n'est pas ça n'est
pas la réalité l'exécutif ne veut pas
renoncer à sa politique de l'offre
pourtant elle ne marche pas et de plus
en plus d'économistes très sérieux et
qui n'étaient pas des opposants à
Emmanuel Macron recommande d'y renoncer
au moins en partie c'est le cas du
rapport Pisani ferry il a été commandé
par le gouvernement et le gouvernement
l'enterre immédiatement alors que c'est
vraiment la piste pour l'avenir
une dernière question vous en avez déjà
un peu parlé sur les collectivités
locales et qu'est-ce qu'on sait
exactement de l'effort qui va leur être
demandé alors exactement je ne sais pas
si au gouvernement de le préciser mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle boycode du coup
ces assises parce que la politique du
gouvernement vis-à-vis des collectivités
locales c'est toujours d'en faire un peu
des boucs émissaires et leur demander de
réduire leurs dépenses les collectivités
locales quand elle s'enlève du
gouvernement et le gouvernement dit
qu'il a augmenté la DGF de façon de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
pardon de façon inédite depuis des
années
c'est ce qu'il dit mais il a aussi
réduit l'ensemble des ressources
fiscales prévues de la taxe d'habitation
puis de la CVAE payée par les
entreprises et puis la compensation est
bien prévue au départ mais ensuite elle
diminue surtout les collectivités sont
privées de pouvoir augmenter leurs
recettes en étant aussi assis sur la
richesse de leur territoire donc que les
trois associations
d'éluses régions départements communes
boycott ces assises un signe un signe
très fort je pense qu'il faut laisser
les collectivités locales un peu plus
libre et surtout libre ayant les moyens
d'investir vous avez travaillé avec
Gabriel Attal sur le budget 2024 puisque
il veut comme l'année dernière le
co-construire avec les parlementaires
c'est une bonne idée c'est la méthode le
mode co-construction est un peu
abusif mais quand le gouvernement
consulte les parlementaires leur
présentent ces pistes bien sûr ça c'est
le rôle du Parlement de participer au
débat et à la construction du budget y
compris en si opposant on a joué le jeu
l'année dernière et tant que le
Parlement n'est pas contourné il n'y a
pas de raison de ne pas participer au
débat une toute petite question
politique mais est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est un budget de droite pour
peut-être avoir une majorité au
Parlement au printemps à l'automne pour
le voter je crois que c'est
la ligne qui devient la ligne unique
aujourd'hui du gouvernement d'Emmanuel
Macron visiblement ça ne suffit pas à
convaincre de voter à l'assemblée mais
voilà ça n'empêchera pas la gauche de
porter ses propositions et sa
contestation d'une politique en effet de
plus en plus clairement à droite d'un
risque d'accident technologies pendant
cette période budgétaire vous partagez
ça vous attendez un 49-3 ça c'est rentre
dans le débat entre LR et la majorité
présidentielle de toute façon le
gouvernement je pense utilisera beaucoup
de 49-3 à l'Assemblée pour faire adopter
ces textes budgétaires la Constitution
lui en donne la possibilité ce qui
serait
menace d'une notion de censure en cas
d'utilisation je l'ai entendu ça rentre
dans le débat entre eux nous notre
objectif à défaut de faire changer la
politique du gouvernement C2 montrer aux
Français qu'il y a une alternative et
puis de porter des propositions
constructives en espérant qu'un certain
nombre d'entre elles puissent être
retenus notamment pour protéger les
Français face à des coupes budgétaires
pour soutenir les collectivités
territoriales c'est toujours très
important c'est non
merci Quentin merci Oriane tout à
l'heure viens dans le club effectivement
on reparlera du fond de Marianne et
cette grande cause de la lutte pour la
laïcité est-elle la grande perdante de
effectivement cette affaire
effectivement ce sera la question du
club à tout à l'heure Quentin on va voir
l'actualité dans nos régions grâce à nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
Auxerre retrouver Antoine compil bonjour
Antoine merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
journaliste à l'Yonne Républicaine et
Antoine le conseil départemental de
l'Yonne s'est prononcé pour
l'expérimentation du RSA sous conditions
oui bonjour Oriane bonjour monsieur le
sénateur hier le conseil départemental
de l'Yonne se réunissait pour la
dernière fois avant les vacances
estivales et le dossier du RSA sous
conditions est revenu sur la table de
l'Assemblée l'Yonne fait partie des 18
départements qui ont été retenus pour
pour l'expérimentation alors au départ
ça devait être que sur une partie du
département finalement ça se fera sur
l'ensemble du territoire en s'appuyant
sur ce qui existait déjà le service
public d'insertion pour l'emploi qui est
déjà en place depuis plusieurs années
d'ici la fin de l'année ça va être à peu
près 8800 bénéficiaires qui vont être
contactés avant la mise en place des 15
à 20h par semaine d'accompagnement vers
l'insertion donc le département pour ça
va toucher à peu près 900000 euros de la
part de France travail pour cette phase
de test donc monsieur Ferro je voulais
vous demander votre avis sur le RSA sous
conditions que le Sénat va devoir
étudier dans le cadre de la loi pleine
emploi au mois de juillet on sait qu'à
gauche le texte est grand CD donc car
certains estiment qu'il s'agit d'un
droit fondamental et donc du coup d'une
régression sociale
moi je suis particulièrement hostile
mais comme toute la gauche je crois et
comme tous ceux qui connaissent bien ces
questions au RSA sous conditions c'est
même antinomique la réalité c'est que le
gouvernement
qui refuse de conditionner toutes les
aides aux entreprises les niches
fiscales veulent mais là dans un
discours démagogique sur l'assistanat ce
dont on a besoin pour le RSA c'est que
tous ceux et celles qui ont droit déjà
le perçoivent en bénéfice qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ne le demandent pas alors
qu'ils y aurait droit et ce qu'il faut
c'est faire monter en puissance
l'accompagnement mais non pas dans une
logique punitive non pas pour retirer
leur RSA aux gens qui ne s'y plairaient
pas mais justement pour les accompagner
vers l'insertion et il y a tellement de
situations personnelles qui sont
différentes parmi les bénéficiaires du
RSA que cela demande une toute autre
politique que celle du conditionnement
du RSA donc oui nous allons nous battre
contre cette volonté le gouvernement il
dit pas autre chose que vous il dit que
c'est pas punitif que c'est pour aider
justement les bénéficiaires du RSA à
revenir vers l'emploi et que finalement
c'est un retour à l'esprit originel du
RMI il dit que ça n'est pas punitif et
toute son approche est punitive et que
fait-il pour améliorer la compagnement
aujourd'hui les départements ne sont pas
compensés par l'État à la hauteur de ce
qu'il devrait être pour justement
la prestation du RSA que fait-il pour
que cet accompagnement monte en
puissance pour des expérimentations
comme territoire zéro chômeurs de longue
durée pour que justement les
travailleurs sociaux soient plus
nombreux et plus de moyens pour
accompagner les personnes non c'est
vraiment une optique complètement
inverse qu'il faut avoir si on veut
aider les bénéficiaires du RSA à en
sortir toutes les études montrent et je
pense notamment aux travaux d'Esther
Duflot que contrairement peut-être un
préjugé à une idée toute faite plus on
aide les gens qui sont en difficulté
sociale en situation de pauvreté plus
elles ont des chances de sortir de cette
situation à terme donc voilà mettre la
tête sous l'eau encore plus à des gens
qui ne se prêteraient pas un RSA sous
conditions aux conditions qui seraient
énoncées y compris parce qu'elles ne le
peuvent pas et bien je pense que ça aura
des conséquences qui ne feront que
accroître la pauvreté sans résoudre
aucun des problèmes de notre pays ou des
bénéficiaires du RSA vraiment s'il y a
un projet auquel j'espère le
gouvernement renoncera c'est bien
celui-là
Antoine vous avez vos réponses vous avez
une autre question
non non c'est très bien merci beaucoup
vous avez notamment évoqué la question
du financement on voit bah voilà pour
pour les départements que c'est une une
vraie question de savoir comment est-ce
qu'ils vont être accompagnés dans la
dans la mise en place de tout ça donc
c'est ça fait partie des points qui sont
régulièrement débattus au conseil
départemental de l'Yonne donc on attend
de voir un petit peu aussi de ce côté là
comment ça va évoluer et les discussions
qui vont se passer au mois de juillet
effectivement véritable inquiétude
parler des finances des collectivités
locales tout à l'heure oui les
collectivités locales ont besoin de
moyens et oui leur action elle est utile
et même absolument indispensable en
s'adaptant à la réalité de chaque
territoire
on regarde la Une de l'Yonne
Républicaine Antoine c'est sur les
inondations un mois de pluie en quelques
heures c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci beaucoup Antoine d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin et à très vite on termine
en parlant des sénatoriales Rémy frérot
vous allez conduire la liste
je dis pas du PS parce que on va voir
justement qu'il y a des problèmes en
tout cas une liste de gauche à Paris
sauf qu'au sein du Parti socialiste la
direction vous appelle à une liste
équilibrée que leur répondez-vous
d'abord j'espère en effet conduire une
liste de gauche
investie par le Parti socialiste et qui
rassemble plus largement possible il y a
aujourd'hui toujours des discussions
avec les Verts qui sont en cours mais
ils ont fait le rassemblement avec les
communistes et je l'espère là aussi avec
Génération moi j'appelle tout le monde y
compris la direction du PS à être dans
l'apaisement et dans la confiance
on n'est pas on est constitue une liste
aux élections sénatoriales qui
représentent les élus locaux en
l'occurrence les élus parisiens on ne
constitue pas à la proportionnelle des
congrants du dernier congrès du Parti
socialiste une liste cette liste elle
est équilibrée la preuve elle a été
largement adoptée par les militants
socialistes et des proches d'Olivier
Faure à Paris n'ont pas présenté de
contreistes au vote des militants et sur
la menace d'une liste dissidente
la direction du Parti socialiste n'en
viendra pas là pour le moment il y a des
discussions en cours j'espère qu'on
trouvera un chemin pour être le plus
efficace électoralement possible c'est
quand même ça l'essentiel en menant la
liste telle qu'elle a été votée par les
militants socialistes parisiens tel quel
est discutée avec nos partenaires de
gauche et quand on voit en plus la
fracturation à droite et l'explosion en
je ne sais combien de liste des
républicains aujourd'hui et bien c'est
la liste la plus efficace électoralement
possible on peut conquérir un siège de
plus et faire élire une nouvelle
sénatrice
toute la gauche et on peut faire élire
une sénatrice qui est par ailleurs du
courant d'Olivier Faure
si on nous fait aussi confiance si on ne
vient pas remettre en cause le travail
qui a été fait c'est l'appel que je
lance aussi pour retrouver le chemin de
la raison ou plus exactement ne pas en
sortir et voilà que le que le Parti
socialiste investisse la liste qui a été
votée par les militants socialistes par
essiens donc vous dites clairement à la
direction du Parti socialiste si vous
voulez avoir un élu trop fort il faut
soutenir il faut investir ma liste je
crois que c'est vraiment la solution la
plus efficace pour donner à la gauche le
plus de chances d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de sièges voilà que ferez-vous si
vous n'avez pas l'investiture du Parti
socialiste vous irez quand même avec
cette liste je n'imagine pas ne pas
l'avoir je me situe pas je sais que le
pire est possible parfois mais je ne
veux pas me situer dans cette hypothèse
du bien vous le dites
on a discuté avec les écologistes les
écologistes qui ont une liste avec
Antoinette gullet et Yannick Jadot
notamment où sont les discussions
il y a des discussions qui ne sont pas
des discussions purement parisiennes
c'est une discussion nationale avec les
Verts pour le moment il n'a pas abouti
mais j'espère qu'elle va aboutir avant
les vacances de l'été en tout cas je
sais que c'est l'objectif du Parti
socialiste ça veut dire c'est aboutit
pas nationalement elle ne peut pas
aboutir qu'à Paris je ne crois pas je ne
crois pas en tout cas la discussion elle
est nationale et j'espère qu'elle pourra
aboutir parce que si à la boutique il y
aura des sièges supplémentaires pour la
gauche au Sénat et pour les socialistes
comme pour les communistes comme pour
les écologistes donc la dernière fois
gauche
socialiste Paris en commun et communiste
et une liste à part écologiste vous
aurez 7 sièges si vous fusionnez vos
listes vous en aurez 8 si on fusionne
nos listes on a de très bonnes chances
d'en avoir huit ensemble et donc c'est
mon souhait au détriment de qui au
détriment des républicains au détriment
du siège de renaissance ça je ne le sais
pas c'est grand les grands électeurs qui
décideront le jour du vote mais dans une
proportionnelle à la plus forte moyenne
plus vous votre score est élevé plus
vous bénéficiez de la plus forte moyenne
pour
pour gagner le dernier siège à répartir
il y aura donc une liste en tout cas
avec les communistes assez sûr peut-être
avec les écologistes est-ce que vous
souhaitez à partir d'octobre la création
d'un inter-groupe au Sénat comme c'est
le cas à l'Assemblée nationale
entre la gauche entre les différents
groupes de gauche sous forme de
discussion comme on l'a eu d'ailleurs au
discussion et de d'organisation
collective comme on l'a eu sur la
réforme des retraites au Sénat oui bien
sûr mais pas de Nupe sénatoriale non de
toute façon il n'y a pas d'insoumis au
Sénat et je crois que chaque groupe veut
garder son indépendance mais que la
gauche
renforce ses combats communs au Sénat
c'est toujours utile même si franchement
je trouve que ça se passe bien entre les
groupes socialistes écologistes et
communistes aujourd'hui merci Rémy
frérot merci beaucoup bien sûr cette
campagne sénatoriale à Paris et ailleurs
merci d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
dans 20 minutes dans le club des
territoires on parlera laïcité telle
menacée aujourd'hui dans notre pays et
l'affaire du fond Marianne a-t-elle
abîmé la lutte contre le séparatisme ce
sera le débat du club mais d'abord on va
accueillir notre prochaine invité
Georges Sérignac nous rejoint